yes guys my name is joe i'm danny and we
just got our first rental rental i've
got the keys
let's show you around and talk about the
figures
okay so what people don't realize is
these shops these shops here there's
apartments above them
these apartments are big they've got
multiple rooms and that means that we
can do rent to rent on those rooms
these are my tenants they've just left
now these are your tenants yeah got
these guys here
yeah so they pay you rent yeah and
you're how old 19 19 and they pay you
rent holy moly
so this is the back entrance of the
house we've just asked attendants if we
can use their rooms to film and they
said it's absolutely fine
that's because we're good landlords
so the downstairs is actually a shop so
we're going to take you upstairs we've
actually got four bedrooms
it's just had a full refurb um it's a
communal kitchen to the tennis show
kitchen um it's got all the appliances
needed everything was ready to go
did you have to refill the kitchen no no
nice so they share the kitchen
very nice so now let me take you to the
living room
[Music]
very nice so this was all furnished yeah
all fully furnished
um some nice surface in here also came
with a flat screen tv
and it's a nice large new area with good
light as well as those windows
and the blinds as well so the landlord
gets one form of rent
from us delhi property group which is
800 pounds
so you paid the 800 pound for the entire
property
okay but we actually get four lots of
rent okay so we ran out each room
individually which brings in a total of
1 600.
so we make around four or 500 pounds per
month
clean cash flow nice
good job and you're literally you're 18
19.
you were 19 when you attended the crash
course now you just turned 20. correct
yeah so how does it feel to have a rent
to rent have the keys to a property that
you control
awesome okay so now we've got the
kitchen the living room out the way
we're gonna go to the first bedroom
upstairs on the second floor
this room right here is actually running
out for four to five per month
nice um the best thing about this though
is we negotiated a two month free rent
period um prior to getting the keys
um so we don't have to pay anything for
two mods so you pay nothing to the
landlord for two months
you've already rented this room out for
four to five what about the other three
rooms are they all tenanted
we've got them in sort of a month a
month a month
so right now you're making more than 500
japan a month probably we took deposits
and first month's rent but we haven't
actually paid the deposit ourselves yet
so good so this one right here is
exactly the same as that one friend
enough for the same exact amount of
money however the tenant's in there
right now so we're not going to disturb
her i'm going to go straight up to the
top rooms
[Music]
yep so these rooms are tenanted the
tenants are out at the moment but
they've given us permission to show you
guys around
so this is the top floor
yep so this one works out for three
seven five and the one opposite is a
little bit smaller
which actually mess up for three two
five okay so all together you've got a
mix of rents but you're renting the
in total you're getting how much sorry
one thousand six hundred overall one
thousand six hundred in rent yeah
you're paying around eight hundred yeah
how does renter rent work explain it to
me rent to rent is where you rent an
entire property off a landlord and then
you rent out each room on an individual
basis and then you keep the profit in
between after bills
is this not like subletting those i'm
not illegal it's not illegal as long as
you don't under the right contracts
okay so if you do it under the wrong
contract and you're not trained properly
then things can go wrong ask ourselves
we're trained by samuel lee
behind the camera we paid thousands of
pounds into our education
and we believe that that's so important
in red to right yeah you've got a
property legit company set up
we've got a company set up we're not
here to mess about this is what you do
properly
and you came on the crash course as
teenagers correct teenagers teenagers
came on the crash course
invested thousands of pounds yeah i mean
some people do people tell you not to do
it people go don't spend that money yeah
of course all the time
oh
but now what now you're making money
because now we've shown that is possible
and you can do it
yeah and you've got these tenants all in
all full
it's all happening beautiful area and
you guys have done super well
i'm so proud of these guys was it was it
hard was it easy did you have to
persevere a lot what was the journey
like
it was definitely tough constantly
getting those
um but we personally we kept going and
then we got the yes
yeah so we're going ahead with it that's
amazing you all know there's a covert
situation happening yeah however some of
us are going to let it affect us more
than others for us we feel like if it
didn't happen we wouldn't be in this
situation right now
so we're actually thankful that it's
happened you feel like the pandemic
actually gave you time 100
give you time you're studying right i'm
studying but because all my studies went
online
it gave me a chance to get a job earn
some money put the money in to rent a
rent so what's next for you guys now
yep so we want to expand our rental rent
business we're also going to start
selling some amazing deals and getting
some vitals eventually nice
and you're going to see us on a winners
on a wednesday yeah
winners on a wednesday every single week
i have a winners on a wednesday
interview someone financially free these
guys are not quite financially free yet
they're making a bit of money in
property they're young it's gonna happen
they're 2021.
every single week every single week
someone's becoming financially free
subscribe to the channel see more videos
like this you can subscribe right here
watch more videos here you want to come
to the property investors crash course
it's free
you can do that right here or in the
link below i look forward to seeing you
next time
thanks for watching peace out
[Music]